Plum carrot.
It smells terrible.
Oh, shit.
Plum carrot.
Let me know, guys.
Just chill.
Plum carrot.
What's this?
Lemon.
Oh, that's carrot juice, you said?
We're running out of time.
Come back for the condiments.
Plum carrot.
Go off.
Go to your table.
Try what you have.
Taste test them.
This is frozen.
So we can taste it?
Okay.
Wait, we can taste it?
Yeah, you have to taste it.
Is everyone comfortable?
Wait, yeah.
We're missing one.
All right.
Which one do we want?
What would you like?
There you go.
Maybe some mint?
Maybe some mint as well?
Can you bake for us in three minutes?
What?
Sorry, bake for us in three minutes.
Okay.
So, this is the first.
This is the first.
King and queen, king and queen in three.
May I touch you for a second?
Which one did you get?
Holy God.
We're going to have to get a little bit of a shake.
Okay.
Let's do this.
So, you guys have to go.
So, I'm going to have to go.
Okay.
All right.
So, we're going to have to go.
Okay, so we're going to have to go.
Okay.
So, we're going to have to go.
Who wants to do that?
Oh, hey, guys.
What would you like?
You can be gone, peasant.
55 seconds.
The king and queen.